what are three rules that someone needs
to know about screenwriting well three
rules I mean that's just an arbitrary
number but let's let's go with it
I think the first thing that a
screenwriter needs to know is everything
has to be connected everything else
that's the biggest difference between a
screenplay and a novel in my mind is
that in a novel you can get away with
saying something on page one that
doesn't connect directly to something on
page 158 and so on but anything you say
in a screenplay has to connect
everything else you say in the
screenplay
if it doesn't the audience is going to
go you know what I don't get is why that
guy was wearing a red baseball cap and
that's the first thing and then in the
fourth scene he was wearing a blue
baseball cap and then after that he
wasn't wearing a baseball cap that's the
guy that's the kind of thing that people
say when they're having a drink or
coffee after a movie right so every
single thing has to connect with
everything else it's much more
challenging because it's almost like
building a building where if one thing
isn't connected properly the whole
building could collapse so I think it's
the first thing a screenwriter has to
know and I think the second thing is
screenwriters should know is that in
chronological order and logical order
and psychological order they have
absolutely nothing to do with it the
only thing that matters is dramatic
order that that's all the audience cares
about if you hook us properly it doesn't
matter where we go in the story after
that hook because we'll figure it out
we'll be so hooked that we will figure
it out
you don't have to even say ten years
later or five years earlier or whatever
you can help to say that maybe but you
don't have to because we're not stupid
you know and that's the third thing the
audience is the main character in the
story not the characters and pleasing
the audience is what made the great
directors what makes them great is they
know what the audience is waiting for in
the birds you know like one of my
favorite examples Alfred Hitchcock has
what's her name Pippi Hedren walking up
the creaky wooden steps to the Attic
because she hears a noise in the Attic
and um she's wearing underwear because
women are always wearing underwear in
the last scene so you know usually white
underwear right the last scenes of
horror film like Sigourney Weaver alien
so she's going up there despite the fact
that she's locked in this house alone
because she's afraid of the birds who
have like tried to get in through the
windows whose beaks you know come
through the windows so why in the world
would she go up those steps
you know she why would she do that so if
you start thinking about character logic
or you know psychological order you
don't get the whole thing you know what
is wrong with her this is what you're
thinking you the audience is you're
watching this and she gets halfway up
the steps and the noise gets worse and
she stops and listens to the noise and
why is she stopping well there's a real
good reason she's stopping she's
stopping because we need time the
audience needs time to catch up with
this story because we need to remind
ourselves we need to first say all these
things about how stupid she is and why
isn't she wearing clothes and why
doesn't she test the flashlight that she
got from behind the couch
she doesn't even turn it on she's just
got it of course at the top of the steps
it's not gonna work
but that's typical and we're going
through all this in our heads but when
she stops on the last step before she
goes to the door where suddenly all of
our inner dialogue has stopped and we're
going okay actually I paid $22 to get
you know scared out of my mind and
that's where we are now
she's gonna open the store and I'm gonna
be scared and when you're ready for that
then she can open the door but a person
who didn't understand that the audience
is the most important character in the
story would have her walk up the steps
would maybe have her test the flashlight
would have a whole different way of
doing
but everything that a good director does
is based on the audience not based on
the characters or or what happens
logically in the next order it's based
on what the audience is paid for what
are you here for and am I get a loose
shoe or not because on that middle step
where she stops you want to leave the
theater you know I know this is the last
time to come one of these stupid movies
is really but ok get up and leave but if
you're still there then she goes up
another couple steps because he knows
exactly what's going through your mind
and his job is to get you to that point
where your mind is blank and you're just
waiting to be scared because that's what
you paid for and that's what I mean by
you know the the it's called a lot a
psychology of the audience that is the
most important part of I think the
screenwriting is knowing that like what
does the audience want to see here not
what not what do I have to do first and
what do I have to expose first what kind
of exposition do I need it's like how
can I grab the audience by the throat
and and never like you know let go of it
you